[Music]
welcome to shore cliff our new home but
we're gonna start our life together it's
absolutely perfect along have you no no
it's only been three months
what's the mini case of love at first
sight uh-huh he absolutely wouldn't take
no for an answer
you just had to marry me I love you
Richard I love you too mrs. Palmer
Oh did you know grace grace suffered
from hypertension which brought in a
bout of ischemia result really sudden
what happened to her she fell from the
tower platform one night so they believe
they never found her body only arcane
I heard that noise again good boys
a tapping sound from last night the
graces old canes is hanging in the
closet and you know how drafty this
house can be honey and are you alright
hell no I'm not alright there's someone
in there anywhere in the tower I know it
sounds crazy but someone's trying to
drive me out of here crazier she acts
better you need to push her along a
little faster Richard but this has to be
setup very carefully she's worth
$2,000,000 alive all I have to do is to
get them to put her in the hospital and
then I have been keen to control all of
our bank accounts someone doesn't want
me in this house someone wants me gone
oh my god honey
[Music]
I'll bet by morning's with completely
lost your mind
you
you